there's a word being used a lot these
days
hero doctors and nurses and hospital
staff are heroes but there's a whole
range of other people getting the
acclaim they deserve from care workers
to cleaners and grocery store staff and
delivery drivers there are about a
hundred and eighty thousand truckers on
the roads carrying food and other
essentials if they are indeed heroes we
haven't always treated them that way
sometimes doing things like denying them
access to bathrooms
Lyoness Woodstock is from Gatineau
Quebec for work he's a trucker but in
his heart he's a husband father and
grandfather and he's a gospel singer
with a lot of faith
[Music]
the music is certainly something to go
to at a time like this I don't think
there's any better
[Music]
a month ago nobody was calling us a hero
we were a necessary evil we were stuck
in their way
we were slowing them down on the 401 now
they're like oh yeah you you go first
so it's great some people are calling us
heroes I don't see it that way quite
honestly I'm I'm thankful to be able to
make a paycheck but I feel quite lucky
when somebody says oh you're such a hero
I know the heroes are the doctors and
the nurses in the emergency room I don't
put myself in harm's way that I know of
they do so as truck drivers we're not
heroes I'm really glad that what we do
helps the economy it's a very important
part and that's exciting it's great it
makes you feel good but we I don't think
any of us wear a cape let me put it that
way well I started off in Malorie town
Ontario cross the border went down to
Baldwinsville New York unloaded a load
there
went over to Liverpool New York just
outside of Syracuse picked a load up
there headed for Fort Erie cross the
border and now here we are in
Mississauga I'll drop this trailer here
tonight grab an empty trailer and head
off to Kingston and basically do the
same thing again tomorrow but there are
some places I don't feel comfortable
going to anymore
down in that New Jersey Jersey City New
York City area I want nothing to do with
that area
I've been running out to Michigan
Pennsylvania Ohio those places don't
bother me too much
it's more rural areas that I've been
running into and there's less people so
less contact I'm pretty self-contained
in the truck here I have my own fridge
and my own food and my own coffee pot
and my own bed and TV so I don't really
need to associate very much with people
except to exchange paperwork it's a
changing world you know you're trying to
sanitize yourself before you go in the
house and take my clothes off in the
laundry room and put them in the wash
machine and the dirty clothes that I
have for the week and all around and
smile and she turns the wash machine on
I go to the shower and then we spend the
weekend pretty much sitting 4 or 6 feet
apart all weekend so it's certainly
different doing our very best to keep
the co mid-nineteen virus out of our
house while we still get up to work and
do the job we will never go back to the
way things were I don't believe it'll be
a new normal
this is just as important as the
sanitizing we do when we arrive back on
I'm not really sure what the future
holds I do know it's going to be a very
different Canada a very different world
I have faith I have a lot of faith and I
know that we will get through it at
least some of us will
[Music]
now is
this is some sort of
or could it mean
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]